foreign
next up we have Monica calling us from
St Louis hey Monica welcome to the show
hello thanks for you guys having me I'm
so nervous okay um
it's just us we're just hanging out
having a conversation
oh okay okay
um I messed up real bad okay so
um
I bought a house
um it's not my primary residence I
actually bought a duplex where I stay on
one side and ran out the other
um I bought it in May I didn't listen to
you guys uh well today Ramsey's show
until uh June so uh Dave said that you
were opposing Ashley uh
pay cash for investment I didn't know
that I actually just went ahead and
bought it and I thought I can do the
little hack where you know you stay on
one side and then the other side they
probably have enough to cover it didn't
go like that they actually uh they don't
pay enough to cover you know the whole
mortgage actually actually they're
really under work I didn't even raise
their rent because they just been there
for about 30 years now so I didn't
either bother to raise our rent so it's
not market price at all and um I feel
like I'm like stuck I want to like sell
it back
um and the lady that sold they helped me
the realtor she said if I sell it back
the most I would just probably break
even which is kind of okay with me you
know I don't mind I don't mind breaking
I just want to get it's not like a bad
area it's really a nice area you know
the duplexes it's it's one bedroom
shotgun like it's it's just I did the
steps wrong but I just that's okay about
my apartment you know what that means
Monica it means you're over 12 years old
if you've made a money mistake and we've
all been there and some people do it
with more zeros on the end and it's okay
we're gonna learn from it we're not
going to make it again and honestly
breaking even is a best case scenario
for you A lot of people lose money on
these deals
okay and so what happens if you sell
this thing and you break even where does
that put you financially
you know because I have my student loans
I'm going to pay off so it really
wouldn't do anything you know it wasn't
making me or break me really I mean I
don't really I'm just want to get out I
just want to get out the deal real bad
would you have to go find somewhere to
rent
uh no no I have like I have my liver
situation everything is perfect okay
this deep text is just over my head like
oh my gosh it's horrible but um well
thank you for persuading all of the
people on Tick Tock out there who are
peddling this crap you got to do the
house hack man they pay your mortgage
for you you get rich so quick not no
thank you I was listening to somebody
else podcast I can't mention his name
but he was like other people money and
I'm like really I can do that and it's
nothing like that it's it's not like
that at all like
but um a lot of people need to hear that
today like you said it's so trendy right
now A lot of people are thinking that
they're going to be the one that gets
Rich doing this way and
they end up in that situation where you
hear the word house hacking just run so
Monica yes you're gonna you're gonna pay
that you're gonna sell that thing break
even and then we're gonna attack all of
your Consumer Debt from smallest to
largest using the debt snowball and just
leave a thousand dollars for that
starter emergency fund in the bank and
once you're debt free and you build up a
fully funded emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and then we can
start to invest and we can start to do
things the right way one at a time with
Focus intensity and Monica can be a real
estate investor later on in life when
she's at the place to do it and it's not
a stressor it's a blesser oh I like that
you like that she hated that it's okay
Christina I'll just let that hang there